good morning
welcome to this joint overview and
scrutiny committee meeting
i'm councillor keith wallam and i'm
chairing the meeting today
which is a continuation of the meeting
which started on the 28th
of june 2021 may i first of all remind
you of
some domestic arrangements please ensure
that you maintain
social distance from all other persons
in the chamber and in the social areas
please ensure that you wear a mask
unless when you are
please ensure you wear a mask when
moving around the building once you've
taken your seat you may remove your mask
please ensure that you use the hand
sanitizer and wipes provided
please maintain social distance at all
times during the meeting and during any
breaks
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use please do not
interfere with other speakers
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting
you may be asked to leave please ensure
that your mobile phones are on silent or
switched off
additionally additionally we will be
using e-voting for this meeting on the
modern.gov
app i'd like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to this
meeting you will be deemed by the
council
to have consented to being filmed by
entering this meeting as a speaker you
are also consenting to being recorded by
the council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press
may record film photograph
or broadcast this meeting when the
public and the press are not lawfully
excluded
so can i turn to the governance officer
to
uh tell us who who else besides the
committee members are in attendance
today
thank you chair so this morning we have
cassandra clements the assistant
director for environment
and commercial partnerships and sarah
cameron the corporate manager for
strategic property
and we have janice robinson corporate
manager for governors and civic office
and myself
thank you and also in attendance is
councillor jessica fleming
a member of the mid-suffolk cabinet
so can i move to the agenda please
apologies for absence and substitutions
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor margaret mabry and councillor
terence carter
and councillor sarah mansell is
substituting for councillor carter this
morning
thank you chair thank you
um can we now receive any declarations
of interests
of pecuniary or non-pecuniary interests
by members please
are there any to declare
no thank you very much
we now turn to the minutes of the
meeting held on the 28th of june
2021 and we need to confirm these
minutes are there any points regarding
the accuracy of the minutes
governance officer thank you there are a
couple of quick corrections
um to make in the minute um which i'll
ask you to note so it's 70.1
members are asked to note that the word
should be country
and not county and then again at 70.35
mems are asked to note that instead of
the word posed the word
disgust is put instead of
that um obviously i was not the
governor's office at the last minute so
i'll have to take any questions but if
there are any
very detailed points i have to take
those away councillor barrett
at 70.15
um the net return
it reads uh 3.67 actually is .367
in the documents that we had
which actually i think they probably got
that wrong when they answered but
um if you look at the minutes
or the presentation uh it is actually a
.367
not 3.67 bit of a difference
thank you councillor power i think that
the answer that was given was 3.67
um so we need we need to we i don't
believe we can
alter the minutes if if we if we've
accurately recorded the answer that was
given
but we don't separately need to perhaps
we do not separately need to ask the
question
of the officer
caster grandin would it be
possible to maybe put in square brackets
afterwards
um what the correct answer should be
because i think that's going to cause
confusion otherwise
if that becomes a record yes chair we
can put a note into the minutes to say
that the figure was incorrect and the
correct figure should read
we can do that that's fine thank you
very much
so with those two alterations
that robert has
suggested and with jan's explanation
there are we
are we now happy do i have a proposal
please to accept the minutes
i've got councillor muller and the
second uh councillor cast and thank you
very much
so we now need to conduct the electronic
vote so it's
over to you robert
thank you chair i will just update the
vote so that it has
the amendments to record so the minutes
be confirmed and start as a true record
with the amendments as discussed
if that's acceptable to you chair um
yeah
we're happy with that the proposal and
the second though
thank you so we'll go to the vote then
thank you fantastic thank you chair
so if members could please go to the
modern.gov app and go to the plus sign
in the top right hand corner of the
agenda
there it will bring up the subsection on
attendance and voting and if you click
on that it will show
the vote in a light blue color
thank you chair all votes now been
received and that's nine votes for and
two abstentions so that is carried thank
you
thank you very much the minutes of the
meeting have been approved
and they will be signed as soon as i can
get to get to signing them thank you
very much
the next item is any notifications of
petitions in accordance
with the council's petition screen
please none receive chair
thank you and questions by the public
[Applause]
thank you chair we have received one
question from
mr thomas morelli which i believe you'll
read out is that correct yeah
thank you yes i will i will read out the
question from mr morelli
and respond to it now his question is
the joint overview and scrutiny
committee last scrutinized the shared
legal service in july 2018.
since that time there have been a number
of occasions relating to successful
or conceded legal challenges against
baba
and or mid-suffolk district council most
recently the claim for a judicial review
brought by boxwood parish council which
was part conceded by baber
this raises the potential issue of the
quality of advice being provided by the
shared legal service
in addition given the time that that has
elapsed since the committee's
last review of the shared legal service
it would seem prudent
for updated scrutiny by the committee to
be conducted
given all this will the overview and
scrutiny committee commit to carrying
out a full review of the work undertaken
by the shared legal service
to ensure that it is still performing in
line with expectations
and is providing good value for council
taxpayers
this question will be dealt with under
items 10 and 11 of the work plans
for the overview and scrutiny committees
thank you are there any questions by
councillors none received chair
thank you we now have
two over two information bulletins
and i believe that we have received some
updated
information updated bulletins
um ask questions about the statement
i've made about the
question uh morelli
will we're going to discuss what we do
with that question
um in terms of um programming that
okay fine items 10 and 11.
um yes there are two there are two uh
information bulletins on the agenda
which have been updated in the gender
that have been sent to you all
um cassandra clements is here
assistant director for environment and
commercial
partnerships and she's here to respond
to any questions
so um and i think councillor
uh fleming you're here perhaps to
either ask a question or respond to
questions
so um did you did you want to give a
very brief
introduction or were you happy to go
straight into questions
thank you chair i'll just give an
introduction to sarah cameron who's our
corporate manager for assets so
working with will berchner our corporate
manager for
public realm together the services are
looking at the land adoption policy of
which you've got a
bulletin for today so i'm here to
support sarah on that item
and then i'm here in place of will today
for the public realm update
thank you very much so
members are there any questions
is anybody uh casa epi young and then
councillor mclaren
thank you mr chairman i'm just wondering
with regard to
um i guess what is the paragraph that
starts there are no legal requirements
for councils
et cetera and it talks about developers
taking on
responsibilities i'm just wondering um
what is the process of accountability
and how is this monitored
these lands that are under the
stewardship of these developers and
their subcontractors
are you happy to answer that thank you
um it's really through planning process
more than anything um where we know uh
that um
uh um puzzles of land
have come forward through the section
106 process
we'll have more oversight of that but
really our planning team and our
strategic property and public role teams
will have an equal chance to to find out
what's happening with those sites
and take those forward
okay i'm sorry mr german i don't think
that actually answers my question
um because i mean that's kind of after
the horses bolted sort of
so to speak so the actuality is if
someone is supposed to be responsible
for maintaining these lands how
do we make sure that they're doing the
job they said they're going to do
um yes through planning enforcement i
would suggest
through land use
but the purpose of this briefing though
is that we are in the process of doing
more work to ensure that we have earlier
oversight
and earlier involvement so that we can
be
ahead of the game in terms of uh what
sites are coming forward
and what needs to be monitored
councillor mclaren i think you're next
with a question thank you thank you joe
um sarah um
first of all is there a
map that i could access to have a look
where all these
green spaces are and are they identified
um there is the mapping browser that is
um on the website
okay that has a layer of our ownership
we are in the process of proactive asset
review working off the piece of research
that public realm had done in 2019
to make sure that we've got accurate
data and we'll be updating that data
layer
as we progress through that work and
going and going on to that up
sort of grading the map um will you
be including parish councils and that
that sort of uh questioning and check-in
yes yeah they've been key stakeholders
because i think we've got a lot of stuff
out there that props is not recorded
something about my own board so yeah
it would be good to know do you expect
councillors to
participate in that with you again
uh key stakeholders in in making sure
that we have accurate data
moving forward um we've got a a a
quite a lengthy programme of asset
reviews to go forward
so that we can make sure that we've
recorded all of our land and property
ownership
okay can i just draw your attention to
the
there's a list on the bottom paragraph
about roadside verges
you've mentioned i
need a bit of clarification um
as to who is responsible for roadside
virtues
is that the county council or the
district council
i i think there'll be a combination
depending on where they're cited
and and that will come through our our
programme of asset review so that we can
make sure that we understand
those accountabilities because that
actually can cause a problem
if somebody raises a complaint
it's difficult for the public to
understand which
authority they're going to make their
comments or complaints
to and back to the
about the planning responsibility
you've mentioned that the planning
committee will make the decisions
about the green spaces in the
development
are you planning on having any
discussion
or update with the planet our respective
planning committees
um yes so we we will be um
creating a a policy out of the work that
we're doing
uh that will will include our planners
uh
as key stakeholders and co-authors for
the policy document coming forward
thank you sarah thank you chair thank
you
thank you councillor mansell uh thank
you chair um
i've got a couple of follow-up questions
from the things that other counsellors
have said
um firstly uh the mapping software that
you
um mentioned to uh councillor mclaren
that can you just confirm that only
shows
um council-owned land not the other
bits of open space that are managed by
private management companies
and on the planning side of things
um now i've been on a planning committee
for several years now
and i've often brought up this the
issue about public open space and was
told that that isn't a planning matter
who takes it on it's just that it has to
be provided
um can you confirm so how are planning
um as opposed to planning enforcement
getting involved
in um this public open space
policy thank you
thank you council um it's uh
the first um question um yes the mapping
browser
confirms council-owned land and property
we have access to
a cloud-based piece of software that
goes further than that and shows
planning
uses as well as private ownership so
that we can keep an eye on what's
happening in the districts
and that's a a piece of software that we
we have a subscription for
the second question
mainly advisory in terms of planning
around land use and allocation policy
and
informing how sites can be included in
the local plans
and our involvement with planning is
to to get a joined up piece of work done
uh so that we have a policy in place so
that we can direct
ourselves to greater opportunity in
directing the land use of open space
thank you are there any other questions
i've got a couple of i'll ask my couple
of questions first and then perhaps
something else will crop
up um one of my concerns about the open
space
uh which comes out under either section
106 or a planning condition or whatever
is that
quite often the management committee
sorry the manage the management
arrangement is time limited so it could
be that after say 10 or 15 years
there's no longer any arrangement in
place so nobody then looks after
the land that has been deemed public
open space as a result of
a planning decision so that anything
might happen to it
the other query i've got is over highway
land
often highway authorities purchase land
for road improvements and
they sometimes they don't take that land
into the into the highway
and the frontage you might well start to
use it
um or when they say they alter a
junction there's bits of land then
that just have no use and just are
abandoned so
and the third category is that there are
places where uh there has been a wide
verge
houses have been built and the um
the the householders have taken the
verge as if it was their front garden so
are you going to look at all of these
cases
as well because it is you've got a sort
of a myriad of different sort of
problems to look into if you're going to
try to come up with
a strategy to deal with all of these
thank you chair um yes is that is is a
short answer um
it will be a process of reviewing the
data that was collated for public realm
in 2019
and then going forward with our
strategic asset review process
to check all of our land and property
ownership
and through that process we'll identify
what needs to be managed moving forward
are there any other queries i've just
got a comment on
the front page of your
information bulletin under amenity green
space
where you talk about um
the land that has not not been formally
laid out for sport or managed
well every piece of land ought to have
some sort of management
um so i i can't imagine that there is
any even if that management is only to
cut it for hay once a year i think that
that we ought to find out what happens
to uh to every piece of public open
space not
assume it's completely unmanaged
although it might be
but we do if so we need to find out
thank you
are there any other questions about this
particular
information bulletin if not
would somebody like to propose that we
note
this and ask the officers to take
account of the comments made
yes councillor grandin
[Music]
where it's referring to
developers taking
charge of open space
on a project that they've had
i thought that going forward that's
going to be
um not not legal
to do have that kind of
payment in place that that management
in place is that correct or am i
incorrect
uh thank you councilman for housing
situations rather than flat
yeah um i'm actually not sure i'll have
to come back on that yeah
thank you are there there are no other
questions
do i have a proposal please uh
councillor muller
yes thank you chad i'm happy to propose
um that we know this thank you
note it and ask officers to follow
forward please yes
thank you thank you do i have a second
to please counselor cast and thank you
and um can we we now have the electronic
vote i believe
uh chair as this paper is just for
noting we don't need to we don't need to
vote on this one
oh that's brilliant thank you okay
so we've noted it we've asked to take
note of our comments and we move on then
to
the um the information bulletin on
insourcing weber public realm project
so do you have any comments that you
wish to make or
would we'll just go straight to
questions
does anyone have any questions counselor
barrett
um i was rather concerned um
in the document where it says
as is um because id verdi
if you're a resident of baber we
definitely don't want it as
is they are i have to say
a poor organization in terms of
delivering the service which is
obviously why we're changing this
anyway with that's been recognized um
also slightly concerned that
obviously a lot of the staff are being
tupped over
does that include the managers does that
include the operational staff
and what what are you putting in to make
sure that
um that we get the service that
really we deserve because quite honestly
at the moment is woeful
and anything extra i mean to give
example yesterday
i was in the kingfisher car park there
were four id verde vans
parked in the lorry park waiting for
those
very hard working two-piece staff to
come in on monday morning
the car park that they pass every day is
in an appalling
position it's it's a terrible state and
also the
entrance to the kingfisher and that's
part of their remit
so you know if we're going to have as is
uh can i say that's not good enough we
need as
improvement please all the time
uh because uh the whole purpose of this
is to improve
and control um and obviously i mean
suffer collars have got absolutely no
interest in this because they've
obviously got their own
in-house department which is probably
functioning far better than
this idea of early contract so just just
an observation
and that's what we're allowed to do in
these things aren't we observe comment
and hopefully you'll take on board those
comments
um councillor councillor grand would you
like to make a comment if you want to
come back
after that that's fine
the barrett um i
more very very frequently you know three
or four times a week at the moment
have to contact will berkshire telling
him about the poor
grass cutting experiences we're having
in hadley
for which will has apologized and he
has assured me that
i could go and print and inform hadley
town council that things are going to
improve be
improved going forward from september
i just hope that that's going to be the
case because
i found the current situation has got
worse
over the last two years so i would like
to
you know we have a certain number of
cuts
for example that clearly
when in certain weather conditions needs
to be
changed so we're
so i hope that going forward instead of
saying we will have this number of cuts
and that will be
it that there needs to be some
flexibility and that coming in house
i think one of the neat things that we
need to
put into the into the in-house contract
is that flexibility will happen
um so that when we have the perfect
growing conditions as we have currently
um we can respond to it
because if as an in-house team we can't
be responsive
then there's no point in coming in-house
because i think that's one of the things
we would hope to gain um by coming in
house
so i hope that that's going to be true
will did say
that he you know and he said i said i
want to put this
in print and he said yes you know you
can hold me to this so
i hope that that is going to be the case
going forward because i think that's
really important
i think um as ratepayers
the public see two big things
that they pay for in their council tax
the bins to be done very well and we
have a fantastic
bin collection service but grass cutting
it's one of those things both of them
are one of those things that you don't
notice
until they go wrong and at the moment
it's been going wrong
really badly um i i agree we've got
perfect conditions
but as long as going forward when we
come in house flexibility
and is is key and that we can have an
improvement
on what we have at the moment then i
think we'll all be satisfied
but i think it always needs to be kind
of written into the contract flexibility
thank you thank you would you like to
respond to that and and then i've got
councillor and i think councillor dawson
after that
thank you chair so just to go back to
some of the questions from council
barrett so
in terms of management there's one
operational manager that's likely to be
tupied over the rest of the management
is part of the
wider i diverted structure and the rest
is the operational team
i i'll be quite frank that i agree with
councillor brandon it's probably about
two years that this contract has not
been running well
um it was coming to the end of the
exceptionally long term you know it's a
ten year with a five year extension and
that's what had been done
um and i think we all felt that the
the motivation of the management
of id verdi was possibly not where it
should have been and so
um very early in my term here i started
the work to look at what the options are
i completely agree as is is not
acceptable now it's not going to be
acceptable going forward
and that is simply a term that was used
in when we were looking at what could
happen
in that we could stay the same when we
could stay with a contract
that certainly wasn't my preference and
i don't think that was the preference of
ons or
or cabinets either and and so we've
started the insulting
in terms of the teams um we've met
uh in a group with the team that's due
to come over
we say dude we're not going to know
exactly until a month before
unfortunately with cheaper you don't
get told until a month beforehand and
we're about to start our one-to-one
conversations in august with the staff
so we'll get more of a feeling
but equally it's a feeling of whether
they're coming over to us or not but
it's equally
an opportunity for us to say what it's
going to be like here what the culture
is like what the worth
work ethics like and the good news is is
that
the mid-suffolk model is what they're
going to be learning from i very much
hope and i think it's been said before
but the mid-suffolk councillors are
happy with their in in source team
and this is going to be a merged team
like the rest of um the rest of the
council
and so part of the work when they do
come over
is that kind of cultural change to get
them working with the teams
working across the borders so they can
understand how we do it
so i absolutely expect to see a standard
change
straight away i'm sure there will be
some bumps we've been sorting a team you
know
that that's always going to happen but
100
flexibility is probably the biggest
benefit that you get from in sourcing
the team
you know the the very i mean it's just
nonsense to say
on tuesday we cut the grass at nine
o'clock if it doesn't need cutting or it
needs cutting on monday
it's just nonsense so you know when when
there is an issue if
as we've had we've had perfect growing
conditions we've had um
great rain and then we've had gorgeous
sunshine if you need to go out and mow
that's where you send your staff if you
need to go and do a math litter pick
that's where you send your staff if
there's damages and repairs to a
playground that's where you send your
staff you know that's the kind of
response that we're going to be able to
achieve in baber like we've achieved in
mid suffolk and of course with the two
teams available
if something happened in one district
we've got twice the manpower
almost to deal with it we haven't
touched wood with or
odd stuff we've never come across an
issue that where we've had to have that
many people
but that will be the flexibility that
both councils will benefit from
thank you very much councillor hill
thank you mr chairman um actually
council barrett did raise an interesting
point as a part of his commentary and in
in essence i think
the assistant director has answered it
uh
to a greater extent um because i would
be concerned that
in the merging of the two teams that we
didn't dilute the standard
of services that were being provided and
i would hope that there's going to be
sufficient
room and time for training of the
transferred staff or any new staff to
make sure that we maintain
our high standards and indeed that goes
across
the piece not only the opera operatives
but also with the management
so i'm very pleased to get the response
to the assistant director in that regard
thank you uh councillor dawson um
yes i just saw a slightly bit of a loss
at this because we're meant to be
scrutinizing it and what i sort of
failed to understand
um is why um looking at this a lot of
the information is relevant but the most
pertinent doesn't seem to be here in
that
i mean i'm sort of wondering why there's
not a spreadsheet with all the works
that need to be done the cost and then a
comparative analysis by year by year
because what we're looking at here
there's quite a lot about the staff the
processes etc
but it's there's nothing here that tells
me
what the annual budget is it said
they've got 715
000 but that's for vehicles no idea what
the whole budget is for public realm
so i'm not quite sure how we can
scrutinize this knowing what the works
are and how much the budget is
and comparing it year on year
um i don't if you want to answer that
but to a degree this is a step
on from when we actually scrutinized the
option
so we've had we had that information
when we scrutinized the options
the decision has been taken and this is
an information bulletin
to to to tell us what to tell us what
has been done
since we made the recommendation to
cabinet cabinet made their decision so
we don't really go back to where we were
there really
councillor dawson you had something else
to do sorry i i just find it odd the
most important information
isn't on here to make some sort of
analysis
really but my understanding is we're not
supposed to be analyzing the difference
between the options
but this doesn't really sorry excuse me
i'm asking the question here not you
um if you don't mind me what i'm trying
to get at
here is if you're drilling this down the
information is not here and
i i i don't know what you think but i
know what i'm thinking looking at this
you know i've done a lot of project
management before and the very basic
elements aren't really in here and they
should be
would you like to respond to that please
thank you councillor dawson so this was
purely an update
given the um risk involved i guess
and uh some experiences of in sourcing
teams before
that i was asked to come back and give
regular updates to ons so it wasn't
necessarily to scrutinize
but more for reassurance that each step
of the way
we're checking that we are against plan
what we do intend to do is come back to
ons once we've
cheapered over once we've got the staff
in and we're fully aware of all costs so
at the moment um until we know what
staff are in until we know what
recruitment we need to do
and we finalise all budgets we've bought
all equipment and everything like that
there's still some movement in there so
i fully intend to come back to lns and
give a more detailed
plan set of information about what's
going on
but this was not necessarily for
scrutiny more for a reassurance of
scrutiny
well i i'm quite surprised really
because
i don't think that's really what well
that's not really what meant to be doing
here we need the information that's what
we're scrutinizing is
i think we'll leave it we leave it there
we've we've done that part of the
scrutiny and
and i now have councillor castin and
then councillor grandin thank you mr
chairman
um how are we dealing with procurement
um and buying in line with the um
the joint council's um objectives
and reducing carbon and environmental um
um the the environmental um
work that's going on um who's doing the
procurement
and are we looking to future proof what
we're doing
thank you councillor casten so all the
procurement has been doing in-house by
our own commissioning and procurement
team so
in terms of vehicles we are looking for
electric vehicles where we can for
smaller fleet at the moment we're
predominantly buying bigger fleet where
that's not necessarily available
but of course that'll be on the hvo fuel
so where we don't have a vehicle
an electric vehicle it will be using hvo
fuel so we'll have that 90
reduction in emissions all hand tools
are electric so everything's moved over
to electric for the public realm team
and so um that that's been happening
probably on going for the last year and
a half or so to move everything over to
to electric um and then of course in
terms of rounds
we're trying to keep vehicles as local
as possible so even though we use an hbo
fleet we still want
journeys to be as short as possible so
for instance in
baber at calais street there is a depot
very small but a deco that we can use
there so vehicles aren't moving um
all over the district equally in
mid-suffolk we've got the creating road
depot where vehicles
are stored so we'll have um stuff in
each
uh in each district to make sure that
those vehicle journeys are shorter
thank you casa grandin
um if
um the two people will come into effect
um in a couple of months could we be
in a situation where a large number of
um isolated staff decide not to move
across
and then will we then have a deficit of
staff
have you made preparations and have you
done informal
does does it are you allowed to perhaps
to do
informal talks with the current
staff i've heard of staff so that you
have an idea of what is likely to happen
or could we be in a situation where we
have a deficit of staff
and then if that's the case do you know
what you're going to do
thank you thank you councillor
yes is the short answer it's a definite
risk so there's a risk register for the
project and that absolutely is one of
the the top ones
um unfortunately with troop rewards you
don't know until
four weeks beforehand who's going to
come over which is very very late in the
day for recruitment
um now we've got a number of things
happening so i mentioned earlier that
we've got one-to-one conversations with
the staff
from idi verdi in august so i think
we'll get a good
um a good understanding there whether
the staff are ready to come over or not
if that's what they'd like to do
the good news is that our terms and
conditions as you'd probably expect are
better than i deferred
and so they're going to get paid more
and have better
working conditions so um it's it's
looking good for them
what they will have to do is work
differently and be managed differently
and so for individuals that's going to
be their choice isn't it as to as to
whether they're
up for that or not what we've got in
place uh we've already got
um some sort of soft um
informal conversations going on with
agencies to say that we may need some
staff at short notice
and what we've done um is take part in
the government's kickstart
program which is people that are on
universal credit putting them into work
for
six months so we've got a number of
people coming into the public realm team
that are both um from the administration
side right through to the operative
side that we can use to help support
during that time as well
so all these people have got similar
kind of work experience in time it just
happens that they're on universal credit
at this point
and so we've kind of got a backup in
terms of agency
and then we've got some kickstart people
that we'll be using as well
you thank you caster scarf
thank you chair i mean i think it's
pretty obvious if you're a member of id
verdi you would want to transfer
to the new organization because your
terms and conditions are far superior to
those at id birdie
i mean it's a bit of a no-brainer really
isn't it one of the things i would
suggest though
is because all staff have the right to
transfer under 2p
you you might get staff that need
significant re-education in terms of
standards of required
now or once they've transferred as
opposed to what they are delivering
now um now obviously it's not a problem
for mid software
because we're not transferring over the
the team into mid support but for
baba members i think what they they want
to seek
reassurance on is that the standards
will go up not down
for mid-suffolk members we want to
ensure that we continue to get the same
standard
and in fact i would go further and say
actually we want to get an even better
standard
because in in towns like stone market
where
we have public realm cut the grass
depending on the length of the grass
depends how much grass is left
actually on the grass and how much is on
the road or the pavement
this leads to problems with curbs
being full of grass and weeds most
particularly
relevant where there are areas where we
cut
the area then next to the curb is twice
as bad
as anywhere else in the street where
there's no grass next door so that we
would like to see an improvement in
service as well it's not just about an
improvement
in paper it's about an improvement
across the entire operation
and if you've got the organizational
structure right and you've got the
team leadership right in terms of
direction that should then flow down to
all of the operatives within the service
and they shall
have a pride in delivering a service for
both baber and midsuffer
thank you are there any other any any
other comments any other questions
um now if if that's the case then
we will note this information volatility
and so we then move on to
the next item which is
the task and finish group
for scoping of transport in the district
so what what um
what we're looking at here is whether or
not
to set up a task and finish group
to look at scoping
not to be the task and finish group to
carry out a full review but
to scope a
potential uh
item for scrutinizing transport in the
district
um and this might this might if it's
agreed this might be
a small number of uh people from
this joint committee um with co-opted
officers
also joining in so
uh really what i'm looking for is
some discussion around whether you agree
that we should
set up a task and finish group to scope
this
and if so what form that task apprentice
group should take
so is there anyone who would like to ask
questions or debate
or think it's a good idea a very bad
idea
counselor barrett i can't see the point
of having a task finished group for this
on this committee i mean it seems like
just a
creation of paperwork scheme um although
we're obviously not paper
creation of screen time um
what are we going to achieve what what
are the goals do you want to actually
aim
to what what are the end goals
a task and finish group to look at the
transport bear in mind that we're not
responsible for transport
i mean uh if we're the county council i
might agree with it but
we're not
uh well the reason for this coming
forward is that transport is delivered
in rural districts by a whole different
many different groups not just by the
county council but by volunteer groups
and and many others um and
what we've found is that there are some
gaps where there
is absolutely no transport available at
all
um and so the idea was across the two
districts to look at
what is provided um where where there
are problems whether
there's a good service where there's no
service at all
bring the information together and
come up with recommendations for
improving the situation
in in places where there is poor or no
service at all
um and the reason for the suggestion
that we set up a task and finish group
is this is potentially quite a wide
uh area to look at and the the idea of
the task and finish group was to look at
what can be
achieved what the what the aims and
objects would be where the information
would come from what the
what the the ultimate task of finnish
group should look like in terms of
numbers
and um who should be members of that
task or finish group
so it was it was a case of rather than
we spend potentially a lot of time
looking at
what that scope should be that we just
ask
two or three people or through two or
four people or
six or whatever to to look at whether
there is
something there that is worth scoping
that was
that was the purpose of it um council
mansell
um please excuse my ignorance you may
have partially
um answered my question because in your
initial
um
words you talked about scoping
and i'm not i'm not entirely sure
exactly what you meant
by scoping i think
that transport across our districts
uh in terms of uh public transport is
dire
um uh and what you've just said so so
the task of finnish group is to look at
whether it's worth
investigating public transport
facilities
is that what you meant by scoping i'm
not i'm not quite sure
in some respects i have sympathy with
councillor barrett because it
public transport options are not a
district
responsibility but we certainly need
some sort of joined up approach because
time and time again
we are told in planning committees that
such and such a place has a regular bus
service
and regular to me just means it happens
at the same time every week
a regular bus service could be once a
week on a wednesday
it's still regular but it's completely
insufficient
um so sorry perhaps i need a little bit
more guidance is what you exactly meant
by scoping
and if this if this task and finish
group decides that it is a worthwhile
project to pursue what would be the next
step
in that process
um well the first answer to your first
question
we can make very little difference other
than to put pressure on the county
council or the government or whatever
to change public transport but it's not
just public transport in terms of buses
and trains that are the problem
there are other difficulties like people
can't get from where they live
to the to the station or to the bus stop
so it's a much broader thing than that
um and i mean members might feel it is
so so broad that we shouldn't even think
about it but my own
my own feeling is that somebody needs to
do something
it's not just about buses it's not just
about trains
and i think it's worthwhile looking at
whether or not
we can make a difference if
if you feel it's not worth the task and
finish scope even looking at
it well that's fine it will go no
further if the task and finish group
a few people meet and come up with some
suggestions
you can then say it doesn't go any
further but
i just feel that somebody needs to do
something nobody's doing anything at the
present
and this is an opportunity for the two
districts
to have a look at what services are
provided for transport in the broader
sense in their district i've got
councillor casting and then councillor
grandin
so is that me mr chairman thank you um
yeah so i'm in kind of two minds with
this
i i want this to bring value
i don't want um to go
through a huge exercise and then
we we lobby county council and
nothing happens because i think that's a
waste of everyone's time
but there are definitely things
that we can bring value to i think the
task finish group
we definitely need them this is way too
big just to take to a meeting or
do any other way we need to um it needs
to be scoped properly
but um for instance we had a development
control
committee meeting where um a warehouse
was being
built and as part of the um
the the matters on that um on that
development
an electric bus um was brought in to
pick up people
that work there there are other things
this council can do besides
send letters angrier and angrier letters
to the county council saying there's not
enough provision
if we my um if i went to my parish
councils and said that i said this was a
bad idea to look into rural transport
i think they would be very disappointed
in me and they think that i wasn't
really doing my job on scrutiny properly
but at the same time i think we've just
got to be very careful that we don't
put a huge amount of energy into trying
to
make county do what we want them to do
when they're in control they're dealing
with things in their way
and they don't really need us to telling
them what to do any more than we need
them telling us
how to empty bins or anything like that
yes i would agree with that yeah i mean
public transport provided by the
or as monitored by the county council
may change and we need we need to know
what changes may be on the horizon but
that's not something we going to
influence or be in a position to to
change ourselves
but there are other aspects to it as
you've said councillor casting
councillor grandin
um i'm in some agreement with the
previous speakers
um i wonder whether it's worth putting
in
a whole lot of effort in time and
resources
by ourselves if we can't
make if we're not in control of what the
end result will be in the budgets and so
on
but what i wondered is i think um
there's an
opportunity perhaps to scale it up
and to
be get into discussions with
o and s of county and make it
a much bigger issue that perhaps we
wouldn't take the lead on
county would take the lead on but we we
and other
districts would get involved in because
you know it's something that needs to be
looked at looked at county-wide really
and
so um and
they are the controlling body for this
anyway
so maybe it would be a good idea for us
to recommend to county
to look at it with district involvement
as as an ols issue and
you know i think that i think we're
allowed to i've been involved with
something a long time ago where
ons and ons at county
and district level um were involved
yes thank you but the reason that i
haven't suggested that
yet is that i feel that that's something
which would come out of the task and
finish group having a look at what
what is achievable what or what is worth
the effort of
putting effort in and that could well be
the outcome um i've got council egg p
young and then i've got council mclaren
and then councillor scarf
thank you
[Music]
thank you chairman um i think um
i would agree with councillor castle
about the need to be
very focused in on this whilst we are
not the controlling authority with
regards to public transport i think
we do have um a role to play in terms of
influencing
and and signposting in terms of um
what we believe that our residents uh
would like to see or what would benefit
from
because the the it's not just a pure
transport issue
it is there are other repercussions from
having good public transport
both in terms of the overall economy
economics of the county and its towns
and
and parishes but also from a well-being
point of view in terms of
the movement of people and businesses so
i i it's i think it's worthwhile setting
up a task and finished group but it
really needs to
absolutely focus on what we believe um
our residents are looking for and then
making those representations to the
relevant authorities yes thank you
i've got council mclaren next
thank you chair um
i think overview and scrutiny joint
and unitary have
got quite a lot of work that needs to be
done
within the programme and at the end of
the day
you're right we have to consider things
where we can make a difference
and hold people to account and i just
wonder
if we've already got a work plan
discussion
during this agenda
i i think i would like to propose that
people consider it
um perhaps in more depth i i just want
us
to be an effective joint overview and
scrutiny committee
and i'm not sure what we're going to
achieve
i i think it's laudable but i i
actually just feel there are other
issues that will come up as well
um you and i have discussed that there
are
situations coming up that need actual
scrutiny
and holding people to account and i just
whether we ought to defer
it to a later date
and get members to make comment
i just don't see i'm not sure that we're
going to achieve what we i
understand the aims but i'm not sure
that we're going to achieve what we want
to achieve
okay thank you council skull
thank you chad um yeah i mean ross it's
largely down to the county council
in terms of bus services around the
county
it could also be down to each of the
districts we all have community
transport
networks one for each district
and mid-southwest is based in stone
market if the district council
felt it was a high enough priority and
identified a number of routes where they
felt support was necessary
there was absolutely no reason why the
district council given the financial
resources
could not direct the community transport
uh services
in their own area to say well look we
would like you to offer a service when
you run this service we'll provide the
bus
how much is it going to cost et cetera
so we're not entirely powerless
in terms of helping our local residents
one of the things that sort of does
concern me is the county
have just launched their bus back better
uh idea lord alone knows what's going to
come out of it
one would hope a large number of
electric buses running around the county
instead of diesel buses but
we we don't know what's going to come
out of that
so surely if we had a look at transport
provision within
our own districts that could feed into
the bus back
better uh idea that the county council
is going so there's
just an eye an idea there um
if we felt as a scrutiny committee that
at this stage
uh it it wasn't worthy of consideration
perhaps the least we could do
uh as we're only 12 members out of the
entire two districts
is actually put it to other members of
the council because i'm sure there'll be
other members of the council who
particularly like to
have a have a go at this topic it
doesn't have to be a task and finish
panel
wholly contributed by members of this
scrutiny committee it could be
other members of the council so before
we before we
kill the thing dead if that's what we're
going to do
why don't we at least go out to uh other
members of each of the councils
and say look this is what we this is
what our thinking is at the moment
we're concerned you know is it going to
be a go up
if they say no we're not going to bother
then
we frankly got our answer but let's not
kill let's not kill it at the moment
when we have the chance to influence
future transport provision across the
county
and we might find that some districts do
exactly what we're now proposing perhaps
not to do
and actually get a bigger slice of the
cake at the end of the day from the
county because they've been more
um audible shall we say on behalf of
their residents
thank you coaster scarf councillor
mansell
uh thank you chair um i i'd like to just
follow up on what the
some of the other councillors have said
um
councillor penn young met said um that
we needed to look at what our residents
are
are looking for i'm not sure that's
necessarily
quite the case because we do have
the active travel initiative we do have
a climate emergency
it may not be what our residents are
looking for it may be what our residents
should be looking for but they're not
necessarily um
so i think and i and i i would like to
disagree with councillor mclaren i think
i think now is the time to look at it
uh partly because we do have a climate
emergency
and also as councillor staff has already
mentioned the county have got their bus
back better
project going and you're right we need
to be
in a position to influence what the
county are going to do with that bus
back better
i also agree with um councillor scarf
that that it may be that there are other
members
on both councils who might be better
placed to do this
scoping um initiative than those people
who are on the ovum scrutiny committee
thank you uh councillor dawson um yes
i'll just add
uh you know we've identified i think the
idea in principle is very good but
actually we've identified quite clearly
what we need in hadley with regards to
the transport the bottom line is
you know the money isn't there at county
so
whatever we identify we're never really
going to be able to
get fulfill the transport needs that we
actually need
so i am um whilst i think the idea for
this
group is good i'm not quite sure we'll
ever achieve anything without
complete buy-in at county level
thank you um councillor cast and they'll
come to councillor muller
thank you mr chairman it seems like
there's two
major different topics going on here
there's some
the um county council are the buses good
enough are they providing the service
what is going to come with the new
reforms and there's another topic that
we
kind of we're kind of going in from one
to the other
and that's what can mid suffolk and baby
do
to improve rural transport and i think
if i was looking at something to
scrutinize that we could actually do
something with and create
um a good piece of work it would be what
what are we capable of doing to improve
rural transport
with the means we've got for instance
hopper buses or something like that
taking people to main routes because the
routes don't
don't um pick up from those areas and um
i think if we if we had an idea
of where we laid what our scope
personally is uh or you know as a
council
to um to help those deal with those
issues
i think that'd be quite a good piece of
work but i just i
i think interfering with them the county
council i just don't think we're going
to get anywhere at all so i think
so it could be a bit of a waste of time
so uh castration
thank you there seems to be a dichotomy
here between
district and and county maybe rightly so
but i'm just wondering given that to my
knowledge we
have quite a reasonable proportion of
district councillors that are also
county councillors
that they should be talking in this way
because i would expect them
to be listening not only to their
residents but to
their fellow district councillors and
taking this message back to counties
as to what we think um you know they
ought to be doing and and
i would be very surprised and i think it
would be entirely
undemocratic if that voice was not
listened to
so um while i hear what uh
councillor casten has said i do think
there is some value
in us actually getting our act together
and saying these are the sorts of things
that we think
should be going on at the district level
to help our residents
so i'll leave it there
if i could respond as one with two hats
on
certainly i would make my voice made
pretty clear about
the and i i'm sure councillor scarf
would too
about the buff services in in and around
stone market
that doesn't mean that we would know
what's going on in in hadley and could
or viewers or
shortly peninsula particularly
so this this would inform us as well
in in any discussions we have at the
as county councillors so i think it for
that reason
as well as all the others that that have
been uh mentioned i think it would be
it would be a certainly would be a help
so where are we now councillor muller
yes thank you chip
i've listened with interest to what
everyone has to say and it'll be
quite interesting to hear more about
this project that the actual county
council
are planning to do with this bus back
scheme
my main concern is is the cost
effectiveness
of you know a public bus service in
rural areas
yeah it's great if people haven't got
vehicles i don't have a car
it'd be quite useful i lived in a
village i could have a regular bus
service
but at the end of the day one gets the
impression that the majority of use of
these
buses are those residents with bus
passes
and the thing is and correct me and
perhaps
councillor fleming can correct me if i'm
wrong that the amount of money that the
county would give to those bus operators
in no way actually covers the full cost
of that journey
so that's about to tend to an issue
certainly i can only speak within stone
market and i've only had one resident
recently
say to me we could do with an improved
bus service
and there is a bus service of sorts that
goes around
stowe thorny and stow up and as you
would know uh chair
but it seems to run at the most awkward
times and the bus that i've seen run
round
is totally unsuitable for residents who
are disabled or a lot of elderly
residents have a big shopping trolley
if they have like what i call like a
normal bus you see on this normal route
that might help people
but i was actually encouraged to hear
following a members briefing we had on
gateway 14
the other week there are proposals to
run an electric bus service if that
gets through planning permission that
would actually run down gun cotton way
and that would certainly benefit
residents on in stowe thorny ward
but at the moment the bus service is
pathetic quite obviously i don't
personally use it
and the majority of residents i know
would use their vehicles or walk into
town
that's that's what i would say but i
think it's down to the cost
effectiveness
and even if we came up with the proposal
there's no guarantee the funds will be
available at the end of the day
thank you thank you um
is there anyone who would like to put
forward a proposal
whether it's just to set up or to not
set up
councillor barrett i'd like to put
forward proposals that we do not set up
a task for finish group for scope of
transporters is outside the remit of the
district councils
do i have a seconder councillor dawson
well i think what we need to do now is
to
use the electronic voting to see whether
that particular
proposal will will be
approved hey chair if i could just have
a couple of minutes just to put that in
one.gov
so the vote that um the vote wording
just to confirm
is that the joint overview and scrutiny
committee does not create a task and
finish group
for the scoping of transport in the
districts as is outside the district's
remit is that acceptable to the proposal
and second
i'll take silences yeah
thank you councillors so the i will now
start the vote
so the vote is now in progress if mems
could please go to the plus sign in the
top right hand corner of their agenda
and go on the subsection of voting and
attendance
there the vote will show in a light blue
color on the screen
thank you chair all votes have now been
received so that is
five votes four and six against so the
motion is lost
thank you um
councillor mancella and then councillor
scarf please
uh well in that case i'll make a
proposal that we do
create a task and finish group for the
scoping of transport across the
districts
thank you and councillor scott i'd be
very happy to second that chap
could i ask the government's officer to
set that up as an e-voting
thing please
so chair just to confirm the new
proposal
um that's just been made is that the
joint overview and scrutiny
i've missed other word committee
apologies let's just edit that in
committee does create a
task and finish group for the scoping of
transport in the districts is that
acceptable
thank you so with your question
so yes um as per the wording on the
agenda for
this item let me just find is it
it's a joint as it's uh being created as
a joint
task and finish group um it'll be for
the districts
as per so
is that clear chair do i need to i think
it's clear
okay um so with your permission chair i
will start the
you members so if you could if members
could please go to today's agenda go to
the plus sign in the top right hand
corner
and go to the subsection on attendance
last voting and there the vote will show
just below the one we've done in a light
blue cover
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is seven votes four
and four against so the motion is
carried
thank you very much um
do we want to leave until we have our
later session to decide who
is who volunteers for that group or do
you want to debate it now
shall we uh the the proposal and the
second
are you happy that council skull i'm
happy that we leave it to the late
session chair but just as long as we
include the suggestion that it may not
be
entirely uh members of the two
uh scrutiny committees as the membership
i think that's the way it works
otherwise we can't
we can't ask other committee and other
members to come into our
decision-making process otherwise it
defeats the option having this committee
in the first place which i have to say
i would agree with anyone thank you
councillor barrett um
councillor mancello and then councillor
scarf um i i'm sorry
i'm sorry i i'd like to disagree with
councillor barra about the membership of
a task and finish group just because
it's been
um proposed by the overview and scrutiny
committee i can't see any reason why
other members
cannot be co-opted or appointed onto
that
onto that group to report back to
overview and scrutiny
for them to then make a recommendation
yes please thank you chair just to
clarify
so um overview and scrutiny can invite
people
to um be in their task and finish group
they can co-opt them in
the other alternative is to invite them
along as key witnesses
so if they're relevant to the discussion
and you want to include certain people
at certain times
at that particular meeting of the task
and finish group you can invite
who you want along and they can come
along and add to that meeting at that
point
kassiskov thank you chair thank you for
that clarification i think either option
is is is a possibility frankly i think
to
preclude other members of both councils
who may have
more of an interest in this subject or
maybe have to make more of a
contribution would be
totally and utterly ridiculous we've
agreed to set up a task and finish panel
if members who don't agree with that
then that's fine too but democracy
is that that's what we have agreed so
whether we discuss it now
or whether we discuss it later in the
agenda i think the option
of other members of both authorities
having the ability to feed into the
process whether they're co-opted members
or whether they're expert witnesses
is neither here nor there i think the
ability to have them
feed into the process is the important
thing
um yeah i've got council council dawson
you switched your microphone on did you
speak
sounds to me like all these people who
just voted for this don't actually want
to sit on it which is a bit
you know we are asking for this and um
i'm sure our other members
uh you know i think you've all voted you
want this so you should be
sort of involved with it be mine
thank you thank you for that um uh
council
if i've given the impression that i
don't want to sit on the committee then
i do apologize because that is not the
point that it's not what i
said actually i just wanted to be able
to use the expertise of other members of
both districts
to feed into this process i'm quite
happy to serve on a
task and finish panel i did not say at
any stage that i was not
willing to i just wanted to be able to
make it something where all members of
both
authorities could feed into the process
let's face it we're two rural districts
and we have an awful lot of rural
members i'm an urban member
but we still have problems as councillor
muller has said in stone market with bus
services
around the town i just wanted to make it
as wide a possible
um feed-in process that the more people
you involve in the task and scoping
hopefully you get it right
um chair i i think possibly with the
review that you're suggesting your best
way forward would be to appoint
expert witnesses at the time because
it's likely that this will involve
and if you co-opt you're then stuck with
those co-opties for the
length of the review where i think it's
more pertinent to invite
the people along as you require them to
come along to that
you know each individual meeting with
their expertise for that particular
point
so with that in mind thank you for that
john that's that's really helpful
with that in mind would would members be
content if the two chairs
um sat on this
this task of finish group and co-opted
other members other elected members onto
that group
and then invited expert witnesses
and the the the
i'm sorry i can i just finish
this this is i what we we don't want to
spend the rest of the day debating who
should be on this
on this task or finish group we've
agreed that we're going to set up the
task of finish group
we want to find a quick way and i would
say
an appropriate way to decide who's going
to be on that on that group
and i i i just felt that if
if the chairs made those nominations
that would be a
a way forward but i've got councillor
muller
uh thank you chair um i wasn't really
looking to be a member of the actual
task and finish group but i'm more than
happy
to provide some information with regard
to my particular award
which i know obviously affects your
awards as well um chair
more than happy to do that from the
stone market point of view but also i'm
no expert on
on the transfer rural areas and i think
you know other witnesses who live in
those areas may be better placed to
provide information on that
i have put forward a suggestion that the
the two chairs get together to
formulate who should be on this task and
finish group
would anybody else be happy with with
that suggestion
i've got a nod from councillor gould
so are we able to take that forward as a
proposal
um you'll have a turn you'll have a
chance to speak in a minute
um councillor scarf you were next
yeah i think it's a perfectly sensible
proposal you too as chairs can pull
together the right membership of the
committees into of course we've
we've moved a motion which has been
passed that we actually set up this
panel
so it's down to you and the chair of
baber
to actually uh constitute the panel uh
and draw expert witness wherever you
choose
to do so council mclaren yes i might
agree with that
thank you um so could we could we put
this forward then as a proposal
um formally seconded by councillor gould
um
my apologies um
so if we if we could then take that to
the electronic voting then we'll see
where we go from
thank you chair just just to confirm so
just to clarify so i've got that the
chairs of the
chairs of the bdc and msdc overview and
scrutiny committees
so there's two separate points so it's
clear who the um
because with them um as it's joined it's
co-chairs
um and just for the next bit too what is
the next part of the wording that we
would want there
just to be 100 clear so is it to co-opt
members on
to yeah i don't think we want to get
into co-op do we want to just formulate
a task and finish group
i'd be happy with two from each council
councillor gould are you happy with two
from each council
yes mr chair
so so i had to formulate the task and
finish group
with um
two members from
each council excluding the chairs
is that clear yeah that was that sure
that's what i was clarifying
that would give us a task and finish
group of six people
yes actually in the chairs okay
so the full proposal reads that the
chairs that the chairs of
bdc and msdc overview and scrutiny
committees
to formulate to formulate the task and
finish group
with two members from each council
excluding the chairs
so members i will now start that vote
and the vote is now in progress in the
modern.gov app
so if you please go to the plus sign in
the top right hand corner of today's
agenda
and go on the subsections on voting
slash attendance
and then the vote will show in a light
blue color
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is 10 votes for
and one against thank you thank you
we'll move on and
the next item is the forthcoming
decisions
list those who've had a chance to have a
look at the forthcoming decisions list
is there anybody who would
like to bring anything forward from that
forthcoming decisions list
as an item for the um
uh the work plans if so we'll take that
as an
at the next item but the
forthcoming decisions list is just for
noting
so moving on to item 10
you type 10 and 11 which we'll look at
in parallel um
are there any comments on
those work plans the first one is
the first decision we have to make is
whether or not
to agree that we should scrutinize
the legal service
and if so should that be a joint
scrutiny which makes sense and
what should be the time scale for it
so are you uh councillor barrett
yeah the this brings back to the early
point of mr romero's
question to the committee the the
trouble
is with legal
advice it is never absolute
because of the whole nature of the legal
obligation so
it's very difficult to actually say that
any advice you get
it would there be caveats at any time
because it comes down to the individual
judge's interpretation of the
information he has in front of him
so to say that we can give
some sort of guidance to the legal
center or look at legal service guidance
as a percentage of um wrongs and rights
would be rather silly because that in
turn interprets
the whole nature of law um it isn't
we're not working on roman law we're
working on our own
uh case law and you know
obviously um it doesn't allow
for an absolute on anything hence why
it would be very difficult to say let's
look at a half a dozen
bits of advice would give and then the
outcomes of those we'd probably find
that we're probably getting 50 50
which is exactly what you'd expect in
that so it's a rather
silly way of looking at that
the only thing i would say is if we are
looking at the quality
of the service being delivered to the
council from
those legal services i.e does it
represent value for money
to the the district council to actually
question the decisions and the advice i
think is is wrong
um maybe we should be looking at the
the level of uh service that we get
because i think uh no one can be able to
give that
cast iron guarantees yes thank you for
that i think what mr morelli was asking
for is for
there to be a scrutiny as to whether or
not
the service is performing in line with
expectations and is providing good value
for council taxpayers so would you agree
that that is worthy of scrutiny
worthy scrutiny within that the contents
of that but i think
he also did mention about the decisions
that the implied decisions he did
say that the advice given so i think
that element
i don't think we could scrutinize
because obviously every
case is an individual case but certainly
the other
the latter part um yes maybe we should
look at it and putting it forward
thank you councillor grandin i think you
wanted to speak
thank you chair actually the um
discussion moved on a bit
since i put my hand up but so yes i
would agree
with what has been said that we can't
really scrutinize the decisions
but we could maybe scrutinize the
value for money and the structure and
the way it operates
and weather and responsiveness
and that kind of thing so um
yes sorry thank you thank you
so is it councilman mclaren yes i just
want to i think it would be useful to
look at
councillor brandon's just said about the
structure i think for many of us
we actually not familiar with how the
whole
process is undertaken i was quite
surprised when i learned
that it's in different compartments
isn't it it's not
one's service so um i think that's worth
i think it's also worth identifying that
um that the public often mistake
decisions and feel that reflects the
competence or not
of the advice given and of course
actually in the
one of the situations
uh identified by the question you know
the person who asked the question
in fact that was a lack of understanding
of actually
the decision that was taken which was
not as i think the question assumed
so i think it would be helpful to look
at the value for money especially thank
you
so could i suggest then that we've we've
got
we've got a gap on um
we've got a gap in december um and
um in october we've october november we
only have one items and we could do
two items in either
october or november or we could do that
item in december i would have thought
that
two or three months three months
probably would be appropriate for
us to set a set a scope and talk with
the
legal service um and with emily about
about what we could scrutinize and then
to come back with for them to come back
with a
a report in november or december
i would suggest perhaps november would
be better than december because
if we're going to be meeting on the 20th
or thereabouts of december
is is that it may not be quite so easy
together
to get the um the witnesses that we
might need along so i
could could i suggest that we we do
we time this for um
for november yeah for november
and the paper from the information
bulleted
bulletin on um the um
land adoptions policy that suggests
that the um uh the reckon
that their recommendations on the on the
policy
uh should be coming back to overview and
scrutiny
um in november so that will be three
items
but hopefully none of those three items
should be
huge so can we provisionally put
the land land adoptions
and the legal service in for
joint scrutiny in november
um
i i think yeah i think we can just agree
that if we uh
um and we'll come forward into your
course um
if we had to deal with that because mr
morelli may well be watching he said he
would
want to watch it he'd want to know how
his
request was dealt with so we can give
him some comfort that it has been dealt
with
it has been programmed and we will be
looking at a review of the legal service
in november uh councillor up here
thank you chad i'm just wondering why
we're trying to load
november with three items when we have
only one item
in february and march where we could
perhaps spread the load a little bit
um yeah i mean
you're right um in march the crime and
disorder panel meeting is is a lengthy
is a lengthy meeting
um the um
the landed the land adoptions policy
hopefully will not be lengthy
and the annual review of local citizens
advice
will hopefully be a light touch um this
year rather than
an in-depth scrutiny as it has been for
two years
you might you might very well um
so um i'll go to councilman mansell and
then we'll see if we can
try where we want to program these uh
i i do hope i'm not putting a spanner in
the works but
can i just question the timing
of your crime and disorder panel meeting
um
because as a um member
of the um west the community safety
partnership
the timing of mid-suffolk and weber's
review scrutiny review of the work of
the
community safety partnership it does not
tie in
with the other members of the community
safety partnerships
timing of a review and i think it it
puts more work
on the officers because they prepare a
meeting for the county and for west
suffolk
at a different time than they prepare a
report for mid-suffolk and baber
so it may i i'm not normally on scrutiny
and i thought seeing as you're
discussing
the march meeting i just thought it
might be an appropriate time to bring
that up and whether that could actually
be looked at
with the relevant managers
at mid suffolk
yes thank you that that is helpful um
yeah we'll do that
yeah um thank you chair just to say that
um there's been an email this morning
that i've just picked up
and that we're being asked to do a joint
scrutiny and this will be baber
members only with suffolk county council
on stella morris
which is a house down hadley road where
there's been problems
and they're asking if we can add that to
the work plan
in the winter months so that we can do a
joint scrutiny with suffolk county
council on that
so and that's for baby members to
approve that
well as a midstand member i'd be quite
happy for that to be put on the agenda
for december but
um councillor mclaren can i just uh
janet what what mantha is suggesting
i'm sorry i mean i i've been actually
asking for this
yeah i i understand i realize it doesn't
affect me
suffolk but i think it is it was an
important report
and i think it needed some sort of
discussion
by babera so i welcome that
can we um put it in the work program but
leave it flexibly so that we can agree
the date with county and come back to
members
yeah that's fine are there any other
comments on the
on the work plan if uh councillor caston
thank you mr chairman i did um wonder
a few years back i don't know how many
members were on scrutiny back then we
looked into the um the online complaint
service that was being overhauled and
we looked at the um the different ways
that complaints were going gonna
be handled to bring down the times
between replies and complaints were
dealt with
yeah i think i'm talking maybe three
years ago or
something like that but i did wonder if
um
in the in the future maybe um revisiting
that
and just seeing how that's going since
it was overhauled would be um
worth them putting on the plan
would that be really a an information
bulletin in the first instance because
if there's
if there's nothing that we want to
comment on adversely or
will get scrutinized further then it can
just be an information bulletin would
you be happy with that or do you want an
in-depth
report i think um yeah i think an
information bulletin would be um
great i'd quite like to see the um
what the times are doing with handling
complaints
how many complaints and how quickly
those complaints are getting them
triaged um compared with
before but that might not be
that might not because you've got to
pick a date and it's very difficult to
pick a date and say that's exactly
what the what was happening at that time
but now yeah it would be
i think an information bulletin that had
information on them
how long complaints are taking and how
we're dealing with them and how many
complaints we're having and those kind
of
bits of information would be useful
thank you
sorry just just to point out obviously
on with regards to council carson's
point
in august we do have the customer
service update
um is that something that could be
brought up at the same time i don't
obviously know from officers but
obviously if it's the same area would it
be
appropriate to do it at the same time to
look at that i
would need to discuss i think with
officers if i confirm agendas to see if
that's
available in the first instance but it
would mean that we do custom services
all together if that would
there is there is an advantage you know
i'm just i'm just thinking that
we're approaching the holiday season to
to
necessarily drop this onto a onto an
officer may not be appropriate but
um if we could ask rob to to have a word
to see whether it would be possible for
for august if not for as soon as
possible
are there any other any uh counselling
younger than councillor mclaren
thank you mr chairman i i know i note
that we have in
may 2022 a review of the overview and
scrutiny committee
work and so on and we had a discussion
at the previous meeting and before about
what happens to the recommendations that
we make and actually how well they've
been carried through
and i'd like to see this particular uh
meeting
actually consider that because we've
never done that at least not in my
experience
uh thank you casa acme i think that was
intended to be part of the review of the
cabinets
of cabinets and council in in october of
um
2021 so if we can incorporate that
um i'm sorry chad i think they're
quite two quite different things chair
we can bring that back
in in may when we do the review of the
scrutiny i think it would be useful to
see how many recommendations you've made
actually where they've gone and what's
happened since would be quite a good
way to to finish with your annual report
as well so
the timing for that would be really good
excellent yeah i'm happy
just also to come back on the complaints
issue i do know that we are recruiting
for the new complaints officer and that
person is not due to start until
august so we might need to ask that
report to be pushed back
until that person is imposed
thank you um council mclaren
thank you chair well um as people have
brought
um subjects up in the public meeting i
will raise the
the um issue of
uh salk uh i would like that to be
considered
in the work plan some review of sarc
yeah i'm exploring this johnson okay
okay so i i'm not i'm not sure um
i did discuss it with the with the chair
before the meeting
and i was going to bring it up in the
informal bit anyway but people have
brought up
sort of is this the is this the support
they provide to parish council i think
it is the support they provide to parish
yes sorry they have a wide remit that's
my mistake
um i i'm particularly interested
in the support they provide to parish
councils and i would like that
scrutinized
and we might have to consider what we
look at
but um it's something that i feel quite
strongly about
obviously we can we can look at the
support but
they are a a different organization from
us so that we
we we work with them we can possibly
influence them but i'm not sure they are
a company that
operates that i'm not sure how much
influence we would have but
you know we could certainly look to see
if they're covering all the information
and advice that they need and whether
there are any gaps
well i think we look at the citizen's
advice which is a separate
entity yes that's true yeah um that's
what prompted me to bring it up because
it does the impact of what they do
does uh involve all of us as
local ward members yeah certainly thank
you
thank you um so we've made that we've
made notes of all the suggestions that
have been put forward
um and can we
agree the work plans um
can we do this by affirmation um or do
we need to vote
sure i would say vote on these because
okay
so in that case um
there's there are two separate work
plans and so
could i ask that baba
members
[Music]
agree the work plan as set out
in agenda item 10 plus the additions
that have been mentioned and if we could
do that first
and then we'll come on to similar for
the mid-suffolk work plan
is that the best way forward for
the baby work scrutiny work plan the
wedding will be that the work plan be
agreed
with the additions made at the meeting
so i will do the paper
vote first so if
members of the baby committee could
please vote
and this will be in the uh under the
item
for the uh baber overview and work
scrutiny
work plan on
just wait for one more vote chair
customer claren uh okay
can i take your vote verbally then
please
four thank you very much councillor so
with that
share that is five votes for um
so i will now conduct the same for the
midsection
so that's with the same wording chair
and that will be in progress very
shortly
and it's now in progress so if members
could please go
to mid-suffolk members please go to the
item of mid-suffolk overview and
scrutiny work plan the vote will now
show in progress in the light
blue
what's happened here
uh okay just two seconds check because i
think
so it's six votes for because councillor
dawson voted in that one so that will
show up so i will have to take that
again
i'm afraid just because that was
fortunate
i'm going to do it again jeff that's
okay just so that we have a clue
so if mid-suffolk members could get
could go to the vote
again on there please so that's for the
mid suffolk
avenue scrutiny plan
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is unanimous
thank you very much right that concludes
that concludes this meeting the next
joint overview and scrutiny committee
meeting
will be on monday the 23rd of august
at 9 30 a.m so thank you all for
attending thank you to the officers as
well
and now can we just wait while we go
you